haïti vit dans un ananas ou ma mère on
s'emballe et bonsoir ou bonjour et
bienvenue dans ce costume taillé épisode
3 de l'état marque de caleçons et bien
mon éducation c'est marvel qui s'y
attendait absolument personne et c'est
normal parce que je suis très très fan
d'iron man et du coup j'ai des caleçons
iron man 1
mais c'est une arnaque puisque ça ne
permet pas de voler comment avoir des
vues ça comment avoir des vues vous
n'avez toujours pas compris l'astuce à
bas prix finalement elle est super bien
marché ma dernière vidéo
[Musique]
pourquoi tu t'es lancé dans le concept
cyprin gaming et comment as tu rencontré
cyprien alors l'époque s'écria m'a
envoyé un mail pour me parler un petit
peu de ce projet qui voulait faire une
chaîne gaming du coup de main donné
rendez-vous dans paris j'y suis allé et
finir heureux et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants n'ont cédé grosse connerie
évidemment au final le projet m'a plu
donc j'ai dit oui la sva faire un six
mois que ces fringues hemmings a ouvert
d'ailleurs si vous voulez jeter un coup
d'oeil vous cliquez là et si vous voulez
pas vous avez en votre mur je suis
michael points quelle serait sa réaction
si quelqu'un tu écrivais sur ta chaine
salut tête de [ __ ] et vidéos sont
pourris enfin c'est complètement faux je
n'ai pas une tête de beats cousus
ensemble quand avait 8 ans
[Musique]
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi t'est-ce ksk 1
tu te crois tu crois que tu étais trop
soit galaxie mj avait pas parlé à tuffé
galetas y tenait un tout petit rôle de
se moquer 1
c'est pas parce qu'on fait un mètre
soixante dix que compte qu'on est petit
passe ici au fameux te sens tu dis sont
mes petits
d'ailleurs je comprends pas parce que
mon père fait un mètre 84 mon frère
ferme à 84 mamère ferme à 84 fin dans un
peu un peu moins quand même façon tous
grands dans ma famille et moi je suis
petit alors il ya un problème quelque
part mais je ne comprends pas ok c'est
parce que je connais trop dans le ventre
de maman
c'est ça hein tu as mais combien de
temps à naître alors ce qui me fait rire
cette question c'est que 46 pouces vers
les 46 personnes qui on me pousse vers
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans votre tête
pourquoi cette question d'intérêt
stables mais bon puisque ça a l'air si
important à vos yeux
je vais vous répondre voici une
reconstitution du jour de ma naissance
deux secondes
félicitations encore tu as quel âge j'ai
18 ans le 27 janvier prochain donc 2014
donc si vous êtes des petits êtres tout
mignon comme les pokémon bas vous pouvez
me souhaiter son anniversaire le 27
janvier prochain sur twitter si vous
êtes des espèces de gros dos du macaque
bien poilus qui vivent dans une caverne
et ben manger des bananes
oui flora tu des vidéos avec des
youtuber des daytona qui fera des vidéos
avec d'autres youtuber
meilleure mais c'est quoi cette faute là
chaque fois je la fais je comprends pas
ce que signifie moody dans ton pseudo
eh bien l'époque il ya trois ans et demi
j'étais dans une team qui s'appelle à
eux m'ont dit qu'un pote avait créé
parce qu'il était complètement fans d'al
youtuber américain e
moody souidi subis tu m'as bien donc il
avait créé cette team parce qu'il était
complètement fan de lui et moi quand
j'ai créé mon coach youtube à l'époque
eh ben j'ai mis mon j'ai gardé ce nom de
clan et ils nous disent quizy parce que
je ne doutait absolument pas que
j'allais faire des vidéos et encore
moins une chaîne en arriver jusque là à
combien d'abonnés as tu commencé à être
impressionné par la popularité de ta
chaine ampute un germe abonnés chacun
des saveurs ma chaîne youtube toutefois
elle même ses impressions et c'est sur
la table est quand même comme tu trouves
pas que sa rigueur avec ses potes sont
incroyables et c'est là c'est moi qui
viens de m'abonner mais ça pourrait être
quelqu'un d'autre j'ai un moment va
tomber sur un espèce de bourse qui aura
92 ans qui n'est pas
tu veux voir ma vie je pense qu'à ce
moment là on fera bois les valeurs 1
[Musique]